[Musik]
am 8 Juli 1982 wird am Green River in
Seattle Wendy Lee coffield ermordet im
Februar 1987 wird Roberta Joseph ha zum
letzten Mal gesehen später entdeckt man
ihre Leiche dazwischen liegen mindestens
47 weitere
Morde und obwohl die Polizei bei ihrer
Suche nach einem weißen Kunden von
Prostituierten schon zweimal auf ein
sehr verdächtigen Mann gestoßen ist kann
sie ihn mangelsbeweisen nicht Ding fest
maachchen Tatort Deutschland die crime
Doku von
Bild willkommen zum zweiten Teil dieser
unglaublichen Geschichte ich bin Stefan
Netzeband und ich bin Mirko Kasimir
herzlich Willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland wir wollen euch nicht länger
im Ungewissen halten und Ahnen tut ihr
es ja schon längst wenn ihr die erste
Folge gehört habt Gary richidway ist der
Green River Killer es wird keinen
Plottwist geben sondern nur bessere
Ermittlungen dank des technischen
Fortschritts Gary Leon ridway führt ein
perfektes Doppelleben der Mann der
nachts grausam und erbarmungslos tötet
präsentiert sich am Tag völlig anders
als ein zuverlässiger Lackierer ein
guter Kollege deinen Sohn hat und zu al
gut vernetzt ist richway ist unscheinbar
wirkt vertrauensvoll und hat ein rundes
freundliches Gesicht das ist kein Mann
vor dem du glaubst Angst haben zu müssen
der ist schmächtig schüchtern wirkt
harmlos zurückhaltend und eben sehr
freundlich zumindest
tagsüber nicht alle seine Opfer kommen
im Wald ums Leben viele Prostituierte
tötet er auch direkt in seiner Wohnung
und diese Wohnung muss auf die
zahlreichen Prostituierten die er mit
nach Hause genommen hat erst mal
beruhigend gewirkt haben denn hier
sieht's aus nach Familie alles ganz
normal da liegen zahlreiche Spielsachen
rum die seinem Sohn gehören der ihn an
den Wochenenden besucht so ein Typ kann
nur harmlos sein so denken vermutlich
seine ahnungslosen Opfer aber von
wegen ich frage mich woher kommt dieses
Interesse an Prostituierten war er von
ihnen besessen oder waren sie einfach
nur die leichteste Beute für ihn ja ich
vermute eine Mischung aus beidem wenn
sich Menschen zu extrem asozialen und
höchstgefährlichen Personen entwickeln
liegt das ja auch häufig am Elternhaus
oder an traumatischen Erfahrungen in der
Kindheit und vielleicht gibt's da ja
Hinweise die erklären können wieso Gary
richidway zum Serienmörder geworden ist
mit einer Vorliebe für
Prostituierte also wenn ich mir seine
Kindheit so anschaue dann könnte man da
schon einige warnignale entdecken die
Mutter von Gary richway ist sehr
dominant und sehr freizüg
mit dem Vater streitet sie sich oft und
diese Streitereien enden häufig in
Gewalt also kein schönes Umfeld für ein
Kind der kleine Gary entwickelt eine Art
Hassliebe zu seiner Mutter beide haben
ein äußerst merkwürdiges Verhältnis wie
diese Geschichte hier zeigt wenn der
Junge ins Bett macht und das passiert
bis ins Teenageralter dann wäscht sie
ihm mit einem Lappen die Genitalien Gary
lässt diese Prozedur immer wieder über
sich ergehen es stößt ihn ab dass seine
Mutter ihm den Penis waschen will er
verachtet sie dafür aber gleichzeitig
erregt es ihn auch das klingt in der Tat
nicht nach einem gesunden
muttershnverhältnis der Vater gibt sich
im Gegensatz zu Mutter konservativ und
religiös und ist seinem Sohn bei
diversen Gelegenheiten behilflich zu
erklären dass Prostituierte nichts als
Abschaum sind Dreck kleiner Zusatz dazu
heimlich ist auch der Vater Kunde auf
dem Strich
soweit so gestört Gewalterfahrungen beim
Aufwachsen ein sexuell aufgeladenes
Verhältnis zur Mutter und ein Vater der
Prostituierte entmenschlicht ich denke
damit ist die Saat gesäht aber bis Gary
wiidway zum ersten Mal tötet wird noch
eine ganze Weile vergehen er ist über 30
Jahre alt als er die Mordserie beginnt
da könnte man sich schon die Frage
stellen wieso erst jetzt wieso im Sommer
1982 wieso nicht
vorher eine Cesur ein Wendepunkt ist
ganz sicher die Scheidung von seiner
zweiten Frau beide trennen sich nicht
zuletzt weil Gary seine Frau nur als
Haushälterin betrachtet hat sie ist ein
Sexobjekt das ihm zu dienen hat und
bereits sie wirkt er mal zur
Bewusstlosigkeit hin aber er bringt sie
eben nicht um das Spiel mit Macht und
Gewalt ist bald selbstverständlich in
diesem Sexleben sein Hass auf Frauen
bekommt seine zweite Frau also
tatsächlich schon schon am eigenen Leib
zu spüren aber damit ist dann 1981
Schluss das Paar trennt sich PU zum
Glück für die Frau muss man sagen so und
jetzt bricht es aus Gary ridway heraus
er wird zum Serienmörder zum
gefürchteten Green River Killer jetzt
kann er endlich seinen Hass auf Frauen
und seine Lust am Morden ungestört
ausleben was ich dabei auch total krass
finde gry richidway ist so abgebrüht
dass er sich sogar noch traut den
Schmuck zu verkaufen den er vorher sein
abgenommen hat und das macht er nicht
irgendwo in einer dunklen Gasse wie man
sich das vielleicht vorstellen könnte er
veranstaltet tatsächlich regelmäßige
garagenverkäufe das kenne ich auch aus
meiner kurzen Zeit in den USA so
hausflohmärkte und da bietet er unter
all dem Krimskrams ernsthaft dann eben
Schuhe Ketten Ringe und und Armbänder
und sowas von seinen Opfern an ein
schöner Nebenverdienst ein unglaublicher
Fakt im Rückblick ja wirklich unfassbar
und eiskalt Anfang der beginnt die
grausame Mordserie und es dauert sage
und schreibe 20 Jahre 20 lange Jahre bis
die Polizei Gary ridway endlich
festnehmen kann das passiert erst im
Jahr 2001 der Wissenschaft sei Dank muss
man sagen die Ermittler können jetzt
endlich richways DNA mit den Spuren
abgleichen die bereits in den 80ern an
den Leichen gefunden wurden eine neu
entwickelte DNA Testmethode überführt
den Green
riverkiller
Werbung okay Leute es ist eigentlich
ganz einfach wer reality TV mag ja und
jetzt tut nicht so ich weiß ihr guckt
das auch also wer reality TV mag der
wird diesen Podcast hier lieben denn
Achtung neuer Podcast von visavi und Max
Richard Lessmann die beiden die haben
ihre Kräfte gebündelt und gemeinsam eine
Insel geschaffen einen sonnigen
safespace eine schwimmende Oase könnte
man sagen für all die Menschen deren
Herzen bei reality und Trash TV Formaten
höher schlagen herzlich willkommen bei
Radio Island das ist der brandneue
wöchentliche Podcast bei dem Lotti und
Max ihrer Leidenschaft für Trash TV
fröhen sie gehen da die legendärsten
Momente der Woche durch und auch die
eine oder andere alte und neue Trash
Legende wird sicher mal vorbeischauen
hier also hört ab sofort rein jeden
Mittwoch gibt es eine neue Folge Radio
Island und das na klar überall wo es
Podcasts gibt Werbung
Ende am 30 November 2001 ist es soweit
die Polizei fährt vor und nimmt Gary
ridway fest er bleibt ganz ruhig als die
Beamten auf einem Parkplatz auf ihn
zugehen und den Haftbefehl aussprechen
er sagt nur ein Wort er sagt okay und
dann lässt er sich ohne Widerstand
abführen und schon wieder sitzt Gary im
Polizeiverhör das kennt er ja schon von
paar Jahren vorher und er geht vor wie
auch sonst er streitet erstmal einfach
alles ab ja und diese Strategie ist ja
bislang für ihn immer ganz gut
ausgegangen aber diesmal ist die Lage
eine andere denn die neuen forensischen
Methoden sorgen für eine erdrückende
Beweislast die Ermittler können ihm
bereits sieben Morde nachweisen aber für
den Rest brauchen sie seine Kooperation
um ganz sicherzugehen dass er auch
wirklich verurteilt wird bieten sie Gary
richway einen Deal an bekennt er sich
schuldig wird er nicht zum Tode
verurteilt und dieses Angebot nimmt
richway an er gesteht insgesamt 48 Morde
und führt die Ermittler an Orte an denen
er weitere Leichen versteckt hat wir
beide haben uns ja die Szenen aus diesem
Polizeiverhör angeguckt ja da gefriert
dir wirklich das Blut in den Adern da
sitzt Gary ridway in orangefarbenender
Sträflingskleidung wie man das kennt und
berichtet wirklich völlig unbeeindruckt
und und emotionslos von seinen Taten
später sind ja auch ernsthaft noch
einige Fernsehinterviews mit ihm geführt
worden er sagt also in diesen Verhören
ich habe die Frauen getötet weil sie
Prostituierte waren und einfach weil ich
sie töten wollte einfach weil er es
wollte ja ja krass ganz lapidar gibt er
das als Grund dafür an dass er 48 Frauen
brutal vergewaltigt und getötet hat er
sagt er hasst Frauen und von Reue keine
Spur obwohl er so gelassen wirkt aber im
Verhör und auch später im Gericht keine
Reue er sagt er habe so viele Frauen
getötet dass es unmöglich für ihn sei
sich noch an alle zu erinnern Frauen
also vor allem Prostituierte sind für
ihn abschauen wie er sagt Müll und
deshalb war es auch okay für ihn sie zu
töten ja und zusätzlich scheint er auch
ziemlich stolz zu sein auf seine Taten
ja rway bezeichnet sich selbst im verhö
als besten Serienmörder aller Zeiten als
die absolute Nummer ein ja was für ein
Monster mm tja Gary ridway bekennt sich
am 5 November 2003 solange hat der
Prozess gedauert dann
schuldig er wird wegen 48fen Mordes zu
einer lebenslangen Haftstrafe verurteilt
bis heute sitzt er im Gefängnis und da
wird er auch bis zu seinem Tod bleiben
mittlerweile hat rageway eine weitere
Tat zugegeben und damit sind es dann 49
Opfer die verbrieft sind aber es könnten
durchaus noch mehr werden denn es wird
vermutet dass die Dunkelziffer seiner
Morde weitaus höher liegt da rechnet man
mit 70 bis 80 Frauen insgesamt und es
ist nicht auszuschließen dass er den
Behörden noch weitere leichenverstecke
verraten wird tja wie kann man eine
solche Mord begreifen wie kann man den
Kummer all der Angehörigen Ermessen die
da zurückgeblieben sind die zum Teil
vielleicht auch Jahre gebangt haben wir
haben uns überlegt wir nennen einfach
noch mal ihren Namen denn diese 49
Menschen sind eigentlich das Thema
hatten wir auch schon öfter in diesem
Podcast die Opfer sind ja eigentlich
viel wichtiger als die Kranken perversen
Täter also die Opfer Wendy Lee coffield
16 Jahre
alt lavorn
17 debor Lin Bonner
23 Marcia F Chapman
31 Cynthia Jean Heinz 17 Opel germain
Mills 16 Terry Rean Milligan
16 Mary Bridget mihan
18 Debra lorine estes
15 Linda Jane ru 16
Denise Darel Bush 23 Jahre Shanda Lea
Summers
17 Shirley Mary sherell
18 Rebecca merero
20 Colin ren Brockman 15 Jahre alt
Sandra Denise major
20 Wendy Stevens 14 Elma ann Smith
18 Delores laver Williams
17 lor and ropnik 15 Gin Matthews
23 Andrea Marion Childers 19 Sandra K
gabard 17 Kimy K pizz
16 Marie Malva
18 Carol chrenson
18 ch Lee wils
18os
19 carry androyce
15 Constance Elizabeth Naan
19 Kelly Marie W 22
Tina Marie Thomson
21 April
26 Tracy ann Winston 19 Bine su F 19
Mary subello
25 pemyette Event 15 delise Lis plager
22 Kimberly l Nelson
21 Lisa Yates
19 Mary exeta West 16
Cindy ann Smith
17 Patricia Michelle barzak
19 Roberta Joseph ha
21 Martha Reeves
36 Patricia yellowrope
38 und Jane do das ist im
polizeiamerikanisch eine bis heute nicht
identifizierte Frau harter Tobak meine
Freunde die Geschichte eines gefühllosen
Psychopathen eines gnadenlosen
Massenmörders es ist die Geschichte des
Green River Killers und damit sind wir
am Ende unserer heutigen Folge angelangt
wir haben dafür unter anderem auf
Beiträge von CNN dem Stern und der Welt
zurückgegriffen wir freuen uns wenn ihr
auch beim nächsten Mal wieder mit dabei
seid habt ihr Anregungen Kritik oder
fallvorschläge dann schreibt uns gern
eine Mail oder eine DM bei Instagram die
Links dazu findet ihr in den showotes
danke fürs zuhören euer Stefan und euer
Mirko ciao
ciao dir hat diese Folge von tatout
Deutschland gefallen du bekommst von
True Crime einfach nicht genug dann hör
jetzt in unsere weiteren Folgen rein
hier warten mehr als 200 spannende Fälle
auf dich wie das Verschwinden von
Rebecca Reusch der Prozess gegen OJ
Simpson oder die Entführung von ursela
Hermann wir hören uns bei Tat
Deutschland